from the air and on the ground exhausted
firefighters are trying to control
forest fires that are devastating South
Central Chile
battling sweltering heat and strong
winds as the fires keep spreading in
areas where the fires have been
extinguished locals are just starting to
assess the damage
in the town of koliko teacher Maria
Teresa shows us what's left of the local
school
these were notebooks she says and
folders all the utilities we had for the
new school year
the government is saying it will
guarantee that students will be back in
class for the start of the new year on
March 1st but Maria says there are more
urgent problems
we didn't expect this it's truly said
for everyone but we have students whose
house burned down and they were left
with nothing it's terrible
and nearby Guillermo conscious campsite
has been burned to Rubble he says he and
his family depended on it
35 years of sacrifice gone nothing we
can do about it brother on top of it I
hurt my arm thank God I'm alive and
saved part of our house using a hose and
buckets it was the longest night of my
life president Gabriel boych announced a
midnight curfew in the areas where a
state of emergency is in place to help
with the operations through the night
while weather conditions are mostly to
blame he says at least 28 people have
been arrested for allegedly starting
some of the fires
local authorities say that there could
be people who intentionally started some
of the fires and this has to be
investigated in a rigorous and firm
manner because if someone has been
purposely causing this they have the
contempt of all of Chile they also have
to face the full force of the law with
winds still picking up the Outlook
appears Grim preventing the spread of
the fire remains unlikely despite
hundreds of thousands of national and
international firefighters at work day
and night and if weather conditions
don't change officials say it could take
until mid-march to beat the Flames for
good Alessandra Al Jazeera